what are the worst things you can do for
yourself to increase how fast you age
stress is probably the most common that
people don't realize especially in our
modern environment and everything and
then sleep is another big one it's not
just about quantity right we know it's
quality as well and there's so many
different ways you can track that now
but if you're not getting enough sleep
and you're stress your body's just gonna
age so much faster and you can see it on
people's faces and all that stuff too
glycation is another big one which is
where those glucose or sugar molecules
attach to the red blood cells so eating
refined high sugar processed diets are
going to Aid you really fast too very
basic stuff but like a lot of people
still don't understand because there's
so much bad information out there